for the first time in over a decade we
could be getting a January event next
month from Apple to announce basically
the biggest revolutionary product that
Apple has announced in the longest time
just like they announced the iPhone that
revolutionized everything now everybody
has a smartphone in their pocket it's
gonna happen again with the VR headset
metaverse deal so in this video let's go
through everything we could see at the
January event because there could be
another product that could be coming
which I'm gonna get into but first let's
get into these leaks way back in June
Ming Chico one of the most reliable
Apple Lakers he's been around for a very
very long time June 7th he said that
apple is going to be holding a special
event in January to announce the new
mixed reality headset and of course
right here we have some other renders
that show what it could potentially look
like of course this is local quality Ian
zelbo actually turned it into this super
high quality leak you can see that you
have this kind of front glass panel
that's all blacked out and within here
you're gonna have a bunch of cameras
looking outwards looking down everything
you have some fabric right behind it
kind of like the same mesh from the home
pod then from this view you could see
the bands that go around that are kind
of adjustable for the head size with the
Shroud you kind of have like this
antenna bar right over here and from the
side you get another nice view with the
button up here so this is just an idea
of what it's going to look like but it's
going to be expensive that's for sure
especially looking at Facebook's meta
Quest Pro but going into make sure
quotes actual tweet from June 6. keep in
mind that was right after WWDC which is
why he came out with this leak he
believed that Apple's AR Mr headset
shipping date will be postponed to the
second quarter of 2 2023 so that is
starting in April of next year which
means that we could have a January event
kind of announcing it with shipments
starting in April and that of course was
actually a delay postponed compared to
the market consensus of the first
quarter of 23 because of all the
Shanghai lockdowns and all of that other
stuff that's why he gave April as the
beginning of basically the orders you
can see right here starting pre-orders
in second quarter 23 with them hitting
store shelves before WWDC
2023 however we just got some reports
saying that there could be some software
related issues causing this to be
delayed even further until the second
half of 2023 and that's actually coming
from Ming shuko he tweeted this out on
December 4th and his latest survey
indicates that the mass shipment
schedule of Apple's Mr headset made
delay until this second half of 2023
because of software related issues
previously estimated as second quarter
of 23 which of course sucks and the mass
shipment schedule of components is still
likely in the first half but then it's
delayed because of some of the software
issues and of course because of that
delay he's looking at less than 500 000
units sold in 2023 compared to the
market consensus of 800 000 to 1.2
million that's of course because it's
shipping later in the year and the final
thing he says which is very unfortunate
is that it still needs to be determined
whether the media event schedule
previously estimated in January 2023
will also get delayed but usually if the
time frame between the media event and
the end product Mass shipment is too
long is detrimental to promotion and
sales so because of that some people are
thinking that we might not even have
a January event because if they have the
event too soon so much time is going to
pass by that people are going to forget
about the headset and that leads to
lower sales so with that said shrimp
Apple Pro who is also a really good
leaker he leaked the whole dynamic
Island sensors on the iPhone 14 pro he
believes that this January event could
be canceled and they could just release
it at WWDC 2023 which is going to let
the devs prepare their VR apps their Dev
kits and then Apple will finally ship
the product in the fall and to be
completely honest I think this makes
sense because Apple announced their
transition away from Intel chips at WWDC
giving all the developers time to adjust
and change all of their apps and bring
it over to Apple silicon and wwc makes
the most sense for this sort of software
heavy things just like the VR headset
now on top of that Mark German also gave
us a new story recently saying that the
arvr headset is approaching but Apple
has internally renamed the device's
software to xros from reality OS which
is really really weird and honestly I
preferred reality instead like the
reality headset reality OS instead of XR
which was kind of like a bad iPhone
iPhone 10r but now don't worry about the
whole January event getting canceled
because there is a chance that we still
have a January event for something
completely different not the VR headset
but something even bigger and more
important to some people out there like
myself and that is of course the Mac Pro
yes Apple said that it should be about
two years for their apple silicon
transition and if we have an event in
January that will still be around two
years for the full transition to happen
now when I interviewed Mark German that
was way back in July on our Channel he
did say that he believes the Mac Pro is
not going to be coming out this year
it's going to be delayed until
2023 so what if we have a January event
where Apple releases and shows off the
Mac Pro and it starts shipping maybe a
couple of months later I mean Mark said
it could even be all the way down to
WWDC but I honestly feel like the better
product for wwc would be the VR headset
so it makes sense to release the Mac Pro
earlier so either in January at this new
event or potentially maybe in March but
then you also got to think that apple is
going to be releasing some other
products in March like the new Macbook
Pros the 14 and 16 inch and the Mac Mini
in March so it makes sense to release
the Mac Pro earlier at its own dedicated
event I think it could totally be a
January event and one thing that could
perfectly coincide with that is that a
couple of months back in October 23rd
Mark German said that Apple silicon Mac
Pro testing was ramping up so maybe that
perfectly aligns he even said that we're
going to be getting the M2 Ultra and M2
extreme chips with options for 24 and 48
CPU cores and 76 and 152 GPU cores
coming on the Mac Pro but that's not it
because the macromis Forum user amethyst
also gave us some really important
details now if you don't remember
amethyst he actually leaked the Mac
Studio and the studio display he
perfectly nailed that leak so we can
trust this guy he has a friend that
releases prototypes of Apple's machines
like the Mac Pro and he said that he can
confirm Mark German's info of the new
prototype Mac Pro being based on a 24
core M2 base chip with 192 gigs of
unified memory he also said that the
Prototype board is gonna have the same
case as we currently have with more than
one PCI Express slot yes there is going
to be more and his friend says there's
going to be six PCI Express slots plus
so that is a very very good thing
there's still no Ram slots no external
RAM still just the unified memory and
the latest Mac Pro is going to include a
very beefy SOC thermal cooler hopefully
copper just like we have on the Mac
Studio on top of that he also gave us
details saying that the prototype
machine is containing six PCI slots and
it recognizes an RX 6900 XT but it's
currently not working so it might not
work with external Graphics third-party
gpus but the benefit is that his friend
said that if Apple wants to support
third-party gpus on the Apple silicon
Mac Pro it can be available in just a
matter of days apple is going to be able
to put it all together if they want to
however he believed that the next Mac
Pro GPU option can make people So
Satisfied that they're not even gonna
ask for third-party GPU support again
because it's going to be that good and I
believe them so to sum all of that up
amethyst said that the Mac Pro is still
in the works with a monster chip six PCI
Express Lanes and all packed into the
current 7.1 case the one that we have
now which I think makes a lot of sense
for such a monster computer and he also
said that there is a stage which his
friends can confirm what the final
product will be like such as what
happened with the Mac Studio and when
that Titan comes the first thing he's
going to do is post the information here
and unfortunately we have not had an
update since October 31st so there's a
chance that this prototype could still
be adjusted before the final launch but
I do think that we could totally be
seeing a January event dedicated for the
Mac Pro because it got delayed it didn't
come out in November like we thought it
would so hopefully January for this
event for the Mac Pro now if you
completely disagree with me let me know
down in the comments below but if you
enjoyed this video click the circle
button to subscribe for more videos like
this one check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next one
[Music]